hello hello everyone this is Nick
Gillespie with reason thanks for joining
us today for another live stream my
guests today are podcaster author and
bompivant Coleman Hughes as well as Cato
uh at policy analyst and legal beagle uh
Walter Olson uh
thank you Coleman for joining reason
my pleasure and Wally thanks for talking
uh to us this afternoon we're going to
talk uh primarily about the uh two uh
recent Supreme Court rulings uh the one
about affirmative action in college
admissions uh that uh involved the
University of North Carolina Chapel Hill
and Harvard and also the 303 creative
LLC versus alinus uh case that had to do
about providing web services for gay
weddings uh we'll get to both of those
in a second but first what I want to do
and let me just see if I can find them
okay first I want to talk about the
legitimacy of the Court the Supreme
Court has an institution
interestingly uh while uh responding to
questions about the affirmative action
ruling uh President Biden was asked uh
has uh you know that the Congressional
Black Court uh caucus said the Supreme
Court uh by virtue of its affirmative
action
uh ruling has thrown into question its
own legitimacy President Biden was asked
is this a rogue Court
and uh the president answered this is
not a normal court and I just want to
point out uh also at the same time the
Supreme Court job approval uh this is
from uh last year at Gallup it's the
most recent that I could find but it has
seen a fairly precipitous drop over the
past couple of years uh down to 40
percent of people saying that they
approve it if you go to other Gallup
records just to give a sense of this
um uh 25 of people say they have a great
deal or quite a lot of confidence in the
Supreme Court and that's down from 45 in
1973. uh Wally if I can go to you first
uh you know is this a normal court is
this a legitimate Court are these
questions we should be seriously
considering
that's three different questions okay
the one you liked the least and answer
that one okay uh the
uh is it a normal Court uh yes it's a
normal Court both
you're getting interference yeah it's a
uh a a police siren I live in New York
City
um
the what the court did in particular in
these two cases uh was telegraphed I
would argue 20 or 25 years ago in
earlier cases and in fact of all the
things the court has done this year the
results in these two cases were among
the most predictable and would have
happened uh had there been some
president other than Trump for example
uh they uh they were not considered
close cases by the majority and so forth
now is the court legitimate uh you know
interesting question in which you have
seen uh I would argue a number of forces
attacking the Court's legitimacy
including both a bunch of people on the
left who combine being sore at outcomes
of cases we can all go through the ones
there but with also being sore
procedurally at the various confirmation
battles which you know I agree that you
know Congress has disgraced itself or
the Senate has disgraced itself at
various times in its conduct but the uh
they are sore about particular vacancies
that they believe should have gone to
democratic a point is uh and then on the
uh the Maga side we all know what Trump
thinks of the legitimacy of Courts which
is he calls them so-called judges if
they will against him
um so so you have as part of the general
um polarization you have this and other
institutions
um uh that are the subject of more
demonization and delegitimization
campaigns you could we could go on all
day about the pluses and minuses if that
there are Libertarians who'd say good no
confidence in government institutions I
am the other kind of Costco of role who
thinks no we're courting dangers if we
undercut institutions that we may all
need to rely on yeah and uh just to put
the court decline from 45 people having
a uh a great deal or quite a lot of
confidence and Trust in in the
institution of the Supreme Court down 45
percent or down to 25 from 45 1973
Congress uh in 1973 had a confidence
rating of 42 that's down to seven
percent and the presidency is down from
52 and 75 which was the first year that
Gallup passed it down to 23 so in a way
the court is mirroring the same kind of
decline we see in the other branches of
government Coleman what about you what
do you think I mean should we be worried
about these kind of broad-based attacks
on the legitimacy of the court is this
something to be worried about
well yeah I mean I think uh the truth is
Biden is attacking the legitimacy of the
court because he doesn't like the
particular verdicts that's that's all
there is to it
there's nothing in the Jewish
jurisprudence of these decisions that
calls into question the the soundness of
Mind of Supreme Court Justices
and
Biden and you know Democrats and
liberals in general have had no
qualms with the legitimacy of the court
on the Voting Rights uh cases that have
come out in the past month
um two of which have gone towards what
would be characterized usually as sort
of the liberal position one in Alabama
and one with a federal oversight uh of
of State legislatures in general
um so obviously this is just you know
this is a political attack this this
should not actually be taken seriously I
think the court is legitimate
and uh and it's important from a
separation of powers perspective that it
continue to be seen as such yeah uh well
let's move on to the ruling itself uh in
the Harvard and UNC case common let's
start with you
um you know do you do you think this is
a good decision
yes I do I do so I mean I've heard many
people
uh on the left sort of hyperventilating
and and about the consequences of this
decision for black Americans and for
racism
uh I mean this is uh I mean that's a
very uninformed fear to push I think
there's two things to say just right off
the bat one is nine states had already
banned affirmative action before this
ruling and I did not recall anyone you
know when I was applying to college in
2013 saying hey Coleman you know you're
a bright Black and Hispanic kid just
make sure you don't don't apply don't
bother applying to California or
Washington or all of the other these
other states Michigan because it's a
hellscape there for black kids no one
said that because no one even had that
fear and now there are people trying to
sort of uncover all the ways in which
it's been terrible terrible to be a
black Californian student for the past
25 years as a way of sort of justifying
that take you have also pointed out in
uh you have a phenomenal article uh that
you write at your sub stack about this
that is in our show notes and whatnot
but
um that we're also talking here about a
very elite phenomenon
um can you discuss that a little bit and
um you know just what what does that
mean in the context of college
admissions yeah so I I am a half black
half Hispanic Elite so when I when I
make these comments I come from a place
of uh of knowledge and love not of
denigration but the the policy we call
affirmative action is not a policy that
has anything to do with addressing the
problems of what used to be called the
black underclass the problems of black
poverty
um the legacy of of racism and and so
forth It's a policy that affects
according to Princeton's sociologist
Thomas espinshade about one percent of
Black and Hispanic 18 year olds in any
given year the other 99 uh either don't
graduate high school to begin with OR
graduate high school but go to colleges
with with higher acceptance rates that
don't practice affirmative action so
this some people want to frame this as a
decision Vision about
quote unquote access to higher education
has nothing to do with access to higher
education per se it has to do with the
ease of entrance
to a very select set of of ivy league
and Elite schools in general which have
a somewhat inflated sense of
self-importance to begin with for
instance if you look and again I speak
as someone who went to Colombia and yeah
so and Juilliard as well yeah which is a
totally different case but if you look
at the the colleges attended by the four
Fortune 500 CEOs in this country you see
very few Elite colleges there by and
large you see schools with like above 60
acceptance rates that wouldn't be
affected by this ruling and they also
they all somehow got good educations
there so I think we have to keep in
proportion what this case is really
about
and can we uh you know here is a slide
that um uh this is uh Joe Biden speaking
um uh saying you know affirmative action
is so misunderstood I want to be clear
make sure everybody is clear about what
the law has been and what it's not been
many people wrongly believe that
affirmative action allows unqualified
students to be admitted ahead of
qualified students this is not how
College admissions were and then um just
this is admit rates
at uh Harvard by racist race and
ethnicity and academic decile and what
this chart shows essentially is that in
uh the acceptance rate for an Asian
American in the top academic decile so
these are extremely you know High
performing students uh at Harvard had a
slightly lower rate than an
African-American applicant in the fourth
academic decile uh or the sixth in the
Hispanic so it it's not a question of
whether or not everybody is qualified or
unqualified but it does seem you know
clear and this certainly came out in the
case against Harvard that they were
diminishing the possibility of Asian
Americans to get in according to the way
that they would have kind of test scores
and the general profile uh was there
without a racial preference when you
look at something like that Coleman you
know what what's your response to that
you just said you're you know you're
Hispanic and African-American you
obviously have been you know killing it
yeah you know but like when you look at
that you know you know what's your
response to that
first of all
people have long defended affirmative
action by saying it's really just a
thumb on the scale it's used only as a
tiebreaker between otherwise identical
candidates you know I've always known
that that's just a lie or just
uninformed by the people who say it but
it does betray a sense that even
Defenders the of the policy are a little
bit uncomfortable defending the reality
of it they would wish it to be more of a
thumb on the scale thing but it's not
and we've had research that's shown that
for
I mean you know several decades actually
Thomas eschmanshade found it was the
equivalent of 450 sat points for an
Asian student relative to a black
student everything else held equal
um and and and just uh one more thing to
say about that
is is
um
actually sorry I just forgot the point I
was going to make continue well yeah I
can jump in the way Biden put it was a
bit of a word trick because he made it
hinge on
uh something to which there is no
definition qualified versus unqualified
you can't go and find data uh that is a
sort uh assorted by those categories in
order to sidestep the question of
whether better qualified applicants were
being turned away in favor of not as
well qualified applicants which is what
we can get statistics on and those
decile numbers uh were a good example of
many others uh so Biden makes a decision
that can't be verified about an
undefined concept uh because he'd rather
not talk about all the things that we do
know I think Walter you took that from
my head because that's precisely what I
wanted to say and Wally you you of
course are also a uh an elite graduate
right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I I hate
to be bringing the average of you uh
bright boys down uh here but you know it
on another level
um is it also the case I mean when we
talk about this as an elite phenomenon
um you know are the Asian Americans uh
who don't get to go to Harvard even
though you know on a kind of you know
straight dossier or you know application
um they don't get in because you know
Harvard has clearly capped the number of
Asian Americans that they want in a
given year
um do they suffer
um because
they kind of they go on to you know
success anyway right
well you hear this phrase again and
again oh they'll be fine and sometimes
it's reassuring uh by people who mean
them well sometimes it's a defense of
the policy uh that points out that you
know it's not as if their lives are
going to go badly uh I would still say
there's a reason these places are so
sought after they do offer certain
advantages might not be that everyone
benefits from those advantages but um uh
but the advantages are there if you want
to go into certain Fields than having
that extra boost of being in a world
famous Department in whatever your major
is uh we'll put you a little ahead
it's just the way it is
you know part of it uh Coleman I when I
was looking at the Harvard case and I uh
was I've been covering this kind of
Brewing over the past several years
really but part of me is reminded by you
know the the idea that um this pit cut
blacks or African-Americans especially
against Asians and it seems to me that's
almost kind of like a Dodge because the
power structure isn't really like Asian
Americans versus blacks right it's
whites um I mean is there some kind of
weird power Dynamic diversion going on
here that's worth talking about well I
think yeah what somebody made this point
which was that when affirmative action
really first started in Earnest in the
early 70s
this country was by and large white
people and black people it was basically
a biracial country with a rounding error
of other immigrants and it was a white
population that was aware that
um of the history of slavery and Jim
Crow and
white supremacists legal structure right
so on a purely reparations
compensation-based rationale
it made a lot of sense whether or not
all white people agreed it made a lot of
sense to try to compensate the oppressed
population at the at the expense frankly
of the oppressor population to use crude
terms right as the country has become
more diverse the borders opened up after
65 and we've got an influx of
immigration from
um you know of quote-unquote people of
color from the Asian world and also from
West Africa
it makes less and less sense to penalize
those people who are not even here for
the uh the offenses of Jim Crow and
slavery uh to penalize them based on the
logic of paying back black people it
makes increasingly no sense and then add
to that the fact that one study found 41
of black kids at Elite colleges are
actually first or second generation
immigrants meaning their parents were
not even here for Jim Crow right they're
just you're penalizing one immigrant at
the expense of another immigrant for
their racial identities which you know
up till recently we had concluded is one
of the most inherently unjust immoral
things that you can do right so none of
it makes sense now yeah if I may Let's
uh look I want to look at this uh
something that Joe Biden talks about
because the the ruling itself actually
does say that race can play or you know
a consideration of race May play some
part in a kind of totality of you know
when you're considering people for
admissions which is had kind of been
found in other groups but Joe Biden says
what I propose for consideration is a
new standard where colleges take into
account the adversity a student has
overcome When selecting among qualified
applicants
um and um you know I mean sometimes
people talk about that as a class-based
affirmative action
um Wally does that you know does that
make sense to you or is you know is
affirmative action fun fundamentally
about race relations and is this kind of
preferential uh you know admissions
policy stuff just something we shouldn't
be engaging in well
what Biden says on the one hand is
totally unacceptionable because of four
ages universities have in fact taken
adversity into account they look at
someone who has done well in high school
despite uh uh various setbacks in their
family or their Community uh and yes
there worth more points so so Biden is
uncontroversially uh you know on the one
hand saying uh fine to go ahead and do
these things once you try to quantify it
or allow them to pretend that they can
quantify it
um and uh use or use discretion
the question arises
um you know are we heading off into some
completely new direction in which they
are just going to introduce class-based
affirmative action which will have its
own problems because it will include its
own problems of uh the students not
doing as well if the reason they had the
low SAT scores is that they just came
out of the poor background not as well
prepared but it will also raise the
question and and as Coleman said on and
introduced in this topic we're not
coming to this uh situation new because
California Michigan Washington and a
bunch of other states already did this
and so we know the range of reactions
which include Sometimes using language
like this and meaning it and other times
using language like this and trying to
smuggle in the old racial preference
yeah you know Coleman what happened in
places like California and Michigan was
there
you know was there a substantial and
persistent decline in you know the
number of blacks and Hispanics who were
admitted to you know the UC system or
the Cal State system things like that
and and if so is that is that a problem
and I just to add you know so that I
give you more questions than you could
possibly remember much less answer in a
single bound
um if that is if you know if it does
result in lower acceptance rights or
lower attendance rights among blacks and
Hispanics is it you know it's not is it
College where that kind of thing should
be addressed uh you know that kind of
disparity
so what happened in California is that
you know you see as as you know is not a
college it's a whole set of colleges
yeah as as Cal State system some of
those colleges after affirmative action
was banned Black and Hispanic attendance
went down at other of those colleges it
went up so that the overall change in
attendance was nothing yeah which is
kind of great right and kind of exactly
what you'd expect
um and and there's a paper called did
the Skyfall uh the consequences of prop
209 which found that the graduation rate
in among the post affirmative action
class was actually somewhat higher yeah
presumably because people were better
matched their incoming credentials and
preparedness were better matched with
the schools they were they were
attending
um one of the side effects of
affirmative action has been that you are
effectively sending that those Black and
Hispanic kids to be at the bottom of
those better schools
um which for some of them they I think
some of them will rise to the occasion
and find out that they really can uh
hold a candle to either all their
prepared peers but some of them can't
yeah there is a interesting in terms of
uh graduation rates
um and you know this this goes into the
mismatch Theory and whatnot private
colleges tend to have particularly Elite
colleges have extremely high four-year
graduation rates uh public college is
even really good public colleges tend
not to have as good and that's partly
because private colleges go out of their
way to make sure that people graduate
because the graduation rate is really
important but it's slightly different
Wally is there
um you know a lot of the attention in
this case has been given to Harvard
because Harvard is Harvard and people
love to talk about Harvard even though
most of us well you know barely be a
wave to it from you know a train you
know pulling through Boston or something
um is there a meaningful distinction
here between private universities and
public universities because from a
Libertarian perspective uh you know like
Libertarians are like oh you should be
and we'll get into this with the uh the
next case Liberty you know private
businesses should be able to
discriminate if they want to yeah this
was something that was missing from the
200 Pages or whatever of Supreme Court
opinions uh in a remarkable way because
again I like many Libertarians looked at
the two cases and said in principle they
might come out in very different ways uh
as a citizen of the state I want the
state not do any racial discrimination
and the Constitution says so does the
Constitution does not say that about
private uh institutions now legally
what the court of hung its hat on is
that earlier Court decisions have said
that title VI of the Civil Rights Act uh
follows the same uh principles as the
equal protection Clause of the 14th
Amendment and so we're going to treat
them as if private and public
universities were under the same regime
and Justice gorsuch's uh concurrence is
that the only place where the first key
lines one
um uh blow on this which is if you go
back uh that isn't actually something
the court has decided upon proper
consideration it's just something that a
few justices have assumed and that if
you and there's no particular reason to
assume the title VI is always going to
work the same way as the potential
Clause the second thing is even if
they're right and even if it does
Congress could go back and revisit title
VI anytime it wanted in order to allow
private affirmative action now it's
interesting politically whether it will
or not but if we want to allow private
uh institutions freedom to experiment
with this sort of thing that we would
not allow of a state institution all
that it's going to take is uh go to
Congress ask to change that law
um uh Coleman if let me pull up uh
excuse me I'm sorry I'm being a little
less than facile here I wanted to pull
up uh slides again
um
I want to get to uh yeah here we are a
uh slide that shows
um about half of U.S adults disapprove
of selective colleges and you know you
brought this up in passing Coleman
there's something like 4 500 four-year
Universe colleges and universities in
the country about 400 of them you know
have any real admissions you know kind
of cut uh many most most four-year
colleges except anybody who who applies
assuming you know they've graduated high
school and taken the proper
prerequisites so we're talking about
small number of colleges here but half
of U.S adults disapprove of selective
colleges considering race and ethnicity
a third approve it changes a little bit
blacks are more likely to approve but
it's still under half of blacks say that
should happen interestingly people who
are Democrats identify as Democrats and
lean Democrat 54 of them approve of
using racing ethnicity you know on a
certain level is this the Supreme Court
catching up to where the country seems
to to be going well yeah I mean
I think either every or almost almost
every time affirmative action has been
put to a state referendum including in
States liberal as California it's lost
um so it has long been a fairly
unpopular policy worth noting that
before 2020 Pew and Gallup asked these
questions in 2019 and back then even a
majority of black adults said that they
disapprove of the use of race in college
admissions
uh and and perhaps the
uh kind of culture of the past three
years has changed that for for black
Americans
but nevertheless people and you know
what's really interesting here to me
is that
back in 2019 when you ask the question
do you support affirmative action lots
of people would say yes majorities would
say yes but if you ask the same group of
people do you support the use of race
and college admissions they'd say no so
it's clear the framing of using that
euphemism affirmative action which if
you didn't know what it meant already
would never tell you what it meant lent
the policy kind of an air of of
credibility that the actual substance
didn't have and I can say it um as
someone who was around back then that in
the early years when this was being
introduced a lot of people took the
meaning of affirmative action to be
things like going out and going to more
job fairs
um you're trying a little harder on
recruitment rather than altering the
standard for acceptance for a job and uh
and and still people will often assume
uh an affirmative action program might
be no different than that
uh you know before we move into the uh
the website case I guess uh you know
Wally you and I are old enough to
remember you know what Coleman talked
about uh before a country that was kind
of white and black and you know
whiteness whiteness is constantly under
construction and it's constantly falling
apart my grandparents were all
immigrants from Ireland and Italy uh you
know when they showed up in the 19 teens
they were not so white after World War
II they and their children were white in
a way that you know was kind of striking
um you know Coleman I guess my question
is do you feel as you know and I hate to
say like as a black person and as a a
Hispanic American I know that you've
talked with people like John Wood Jr and
Thomas Chatterton Williams and Camille
Foster and others who are also uh black
or uh you know or part black
um you know the country that you seem to
be living in and growing up in and
you're still under 30 but you know
you're being told or everybody's being
told that things are getting worse for
minorities for racial and ethnic
minorities that has not been your
experience
um can you talk about like what's the
mismatch and how do we get to you know
this isn't about court cases or anything
but how do we get to a better
conversation about these questions which
isn't tribal or political or ideological
yeah I mean the source of the mismatch
in my view comes mainly from social
media and smartphone culture like back
when I was I don't know say let's say 12
or something like 2008
most people aren't on Facebook most
people aren't on Twitter
um people are judging the state of
society by like their conversations with
their neighbors and their co-workers and
the local newspaper
um then what happens in 2013-14 is say
if something happened in in a in like a
sleepy town in Indiana or Ferguson
Missouri or Ferguson Missouri yeah and
really anywhere you know prior to social
media that would have been reported the
next day in the local newspaper where it
gets you know the journalist talks to
the police talks to everyone gives a
fact checked kind of get kept version of
what happened and that's that's that's
all that happens post 2013 that same
event is filmed by someone on their
smartphone who probably films the second
half of it without filming the lead up
it circulates it gets millions of views
with within a few days out of context of
any sort of of fact checking or
journalism and that's how people get
their impression of what's going on in
the country and then it gets
algorithmically boosted so that it's
preferentially shown precisely to the
people that would be upset most by it
and that's how the entire information
landscape changed radically without
anyone in big Tech meaning to they
fundamentally changed the perceptions of
people in the country and it's it's
consistent with Eric Kaufman the
political scientist has done research
finding that black people who are on
social media report experiencing much
more racism in their personal lives
compared to black people who are off
social media that's a correlation so it
doesn't necessarily imply causation but
it is consistent with the story that
people's real sense of reality is being
warped by the algorithm algorithmically
boosted content on social media and
pervasiveness of smartphones I wonder if
that also works I you know I spend a lot
of time with white people who are very
much on social media and they believe
the worst of all you know that we're
living in in a hellscape where every
subway ride you are going to be accosted
by you know an endless uh parade of
homeless people
Etc or that you know you you can't walk
down a street in New York without having
an African-American you know a young
African-American man punching a an
Asian-American woman in the face you
know it it that's fascinating
um and I guess it you know as long as
we're talking about the web or you know
smartphones and social media we might as
well move into the next case uh 303
creative limited like liability
Corporation versus Elena's uh Wally I'm
gonna go to you first because uh among
many other things you are a gay man uh
this is a case that it uh you know is
about a a woman who ran a web uh a
website service
who refused to
um who said she would refuse to make
websites for gay weddings or gay married
couples
um and that she shouldn't have to in the
Colorado law anti-discrimination law was
stifling or was compelling her
to make speech she didn't believe in you
know how how does this ruling you know
how do you respond to this rolling is it
is it a good legal ruling
um is it a good social ruling how do you
kind of incorporate this into your world
well let me respond to it as a legal
ruling because that's what I get paid to
do is legal punditry and I will say um
first as I mentioned the very beginning
of the program uh you could see this
coming a long long way away
on the racial preferences at
University's case we all remember uh 20
25 years ago some of the justices that
were in the middle and and the decide
had the deciding votes on those cases
said it's okay for now but it's going to
have to be phased out uh Senator Dary
O'Connor and others said we can't go on
having this 25 years from now so that's
what that one was Telegraph and this one
not just masterpiece cake shop which is
five years ago in which the court came
up to and then refused to decide
um a closely related issue
um you could tell from the way the
justices were writing that there was
going to be a majority for uh something
like this when the speech was framed up
in the correct way in other words more
clearly a speech than than cake
decorating which is a very you know gray
area kind of thing
um that when a case came along in which
it clearly was speech that the
complainant would win I would go back to
1995 and the Court's unanimous ruling in
the Boston Irish parade case this was
one where
um a gay writes Irish group
who wanted to march in the Boston Irish
parade
management of the parade said no we are
you know uh staunch Believers in
Catholic teachings uh this would be at
variance with and and the court uh took
it and ruled 9-0 including all the big
liberals and written by Justice Suiter
who is not anti-gay
um that uh they had the right to turn
them away uh the
um the one thing that is a little
different
um that uh needed clarification is that
this applies in commercial situations as
opposed to the parade thing which was a
purely non-profit volunteer type of
thing and we can get to that but I want
to emphasize two other things that are
easy to miss about the 303 creative case
one of them is uh it did not go to the
court based on her
rights of free exercise of religion that
deliberately did not take the religious
liberty angle and made it a free speech
one now that is important in percussions
uh because she won on Free Speech rather
than on religious uh Liberty it means
that everyone else
in who objected to being forced to to uh
create some uh piece of speech or a song
or uh whatever it is
um is going to be able to realign her
kiss in fact if you want to take a
provocative fact situation the next time
that a gay website designer wants to
turn down someone who wants to sign you
know
honoring their confirmation in the
religion that they've just changed to
whatever uh this law will protect that
that secularism who says I'm sorry but I
just can't bring myself to recite the
things that you would need as part of a
proper site celebrating your religious
conversion so so it's not in that sense
really a gay rights case it's in
everyone writes kiss is it um you know
does I guess does it matter that it's
come out that the the customer that was
kind of referenced in the brief didn't
exist or apparently doesn't exist so
this was hypothetical does that matter
at all uh the shorter answer is is no
but let me back up a little bit because
it's worth catching up on the procedural
background which especially in First
Amendment cases is different from other
legal controversies that reach the
Supreme Court or other courts you know
the general background rule is that you
can't get a Court ruling uh unless you
have an actual injury from the law which
means mostly that they've enforced it
against you so she wouldn't get in until
some Colorado agency had fined her or
done whatever the penalty is and that's
how
oh it usually works but especially for
First Amendment law and also for some
other constitutional rights that are
considered uh important ones uh the
courts have uh for a long time uh
developed procedure under which you can
do a so-called pre-inforcement Challenge
and you can go in saying I have a
reasonable fear that the law will be
enforced against me so even though I
haven't sold a copy of the censored book
or whatever the thing is I deserve a
ruling on that now in her case
um she
um uh
they tried a number of theories the
theory that she won on in the 10th
circuit Federal appeals court was not
the theory that she had actually tried
to do any business it was a pure
pre-inforcement challenge in which the
premise was we're going to decide this
case for you uh based on uh the the
track record of First Amendment
pre-ament challenge uh pre-inforcement
challenges whether or not you have ever
tried to do business and the Supreme
Court took the case as it found it uh
said uh you know it's up to us on a
classic
um challenge of this type we don't care
any more than the 10th circuit card
whether she had any live clients so
that's the short answer as to why that
whole thing is irrelevant for purposes
of how the Court ruled it might possibly
be relevant if they believed that
someone was trying to put one over by
generating false evidence then there
could be some sort of legal discipline
case but no one has put forward a
plausible Theory as to who did that
um let me just find the slide that I was
hoping to go to oop I'm sorry Excuse me
while I scatter through this okay so uh
this is from Justice sotomayor's descent
um she said uh today the court for the
first time in its history grants a
business open to the public a
constitutional right to refuse to serve
members of a protected class Coleman you
know how do you respond to that like are
you does that is she right does that
concern you or do you feel
you know that the way Wally was talking
about this actually is is the better way
to view it
it seems like a category error to me
because this this business presumably
you know if if I were wanting to set up
a website for my gay friend but I was
really the customer and I was paying for
it for whatever reason they would have
refused me just the same and I'm not gay
right so it seems like the logic of the
case is not that it's refusing to to
serve members of a protected class but
it's refusing to execute Services
related to speech and and writing that
uh that it doesn't where it doesn't want
to say those words and express those
beliefs I think that's the better way to
conceive of this issue and I I'm I'm
curious just as a matter of you know for
people who feel
sotomayor's position is right how their
intuitions might change if it were if it
were instead a Muslim uh rather than a
Christian and you were asking a Muslim
website designer to
um
you know make a I don't know make a
website depicting the prophet Muhammad
or something I mean that's an extreme
example but to do anything I'm curious
if if people would have the same
intuition that really what's important
is that we force that that website maker
to uh to to say something here she
doesn't want to say or whether the
important thing is to to uh be on the
opposite side
yeah Wally
um how does how does this case fit into
questions of public accommodations and
you know I know uh Coleman I I am not uh
smearing you with the label libertarian
I know that you know you are libertarian
adjacent or maybe uh moving in that
direction you have unnatural libertarian
Tendencies or whatever but
um you know but Wally you are a a
self-defined Libertarian and one of the
odd things about Libertarians is that
they'll always say you know racism is
the most vile form of collectivism and
they believe you know people should be
able to free uh you know live freely and
do whatever is consensual among adults
and all of that kind of stuff
um and they Libertarians take a dark
View at anti-discrimination laws and
public accommodation laws that say if
you open your business to the public
you've got to serve everybody does this
case fundamentally challenge or engage
that kind of issue
brushes past it and I'll say by way of
uh background that exactly half the
states currently have public
accommodation laws in which sexual
orientation or gender identity are one
of the productive categories so by that
definition half of America was already a
hellscape i
but will go along with your term for gay
people or also or else you may not
notice it because in fact in those other
25 States it's very hard to find any
actual instances in which other than
with wedding services and a couple of
very narrowly defined controversies very
difficult to find any difference in in
treatment
um
Libertarians
um uh you're right you're absolutely
right uh have a uh uh I think Justified
suspicion of the attempt to use public
accommodation laws to
override the uh independent Judgment of
businesses of how to serve and I say
brushed against it because both the
majority and the minority in the 303
creative case
uh did turn to history
um there were questions uh
um which may shed light on whether
public accommodation laws were a fairly
rare and exceptional thing or were
something that were completely accepted
even in the grand old libertarian
classical liberal period uh it was
certainly accepted that some businesses
like
oh ends to stay the night in a country
where you might freeze to death if they
wouldn't take you in were under a public
accommodation obligation we do know that
about anglo-american history
um and some others
um uh closely related in the hospitality
business uh what about someone who uh
would fix your shoes what about someone
who would bake you a kick well
the majority brushes by a theory that
um uh if you look at old instances where
classical liberal societies accepted the
public accommodation
um idea the idea that businesses on
undertook a particular accommodation
that it uh aside from the hospitality
and the road cases they were very often
Monopoly cases if you're going to give a
company a monopoly over something you
darn well are going to give them an
obligation to serve every single
customer
um and then the dissent by Sotomayor
said oh no no no by the time she was
done talking about it you would really
would think that every single person who
ever offered any services or products
was under a public accommodations
obligation which I think is not actually
true if you go back to the to the old
law books so so they both found it worth
engaging and yet on one level it what
they said does not change uh The Sweep
of these laws it doesn't give me the
opportunity to say as a Libertarian that
the stakes of social division go down if
you don't Define ever every single
florist and calligrapher as a public
accommodation if you take a reasonable
view that you know some things are big
and public enough like theaters that uh
there is some sort of public stigma in
not being allowed but if you try to
extend it to every little uh one person
business you are going to have more
social division you just are can I ask
Wally as as a gay man who I believe is
married correct uh well Steve I think so
okay yeah
um
um maybe married in multiple States I
don't know you know it's like uh but you
know how when you read about somebody
who is like you know what like I'll make
you a website but like I'll be damned if
I'm gonna you know write you know you
know here's our gift registry for a
wedding or all you can buy a cake I
baked but I'll be damned if I'm gonna
write you know best wishes you know
except I mean like how you know how do
you respond to that on an end of visual
level well I there's a great line from
uh Zora Neil Hurston about uh being
discriminated against you I can't
imagine she said why people would want
to deprive themselves of the Delight of
my company
that is a confident person's uh response
to being distributed against obviously
she lived in bad circumstances in the
South and she knew perfectly well that
there was more and worse to be had from
discrimination but I love the attitude
because especially when the
Discrimination is just symbolic and is
not actually causing you to uh not be
able to get the the job or the home or
whatever uh you just brush it off as
people who haven't learned what they
need to know about the world uh it's um
um and and here we got to the series of
cases involving masterpiece cake shop
and the flowers case and now the website
case which is uh it's very hard to find
any of those cases in which uh gay
people getting married uh or these date
back to the point where you couldn't get
married and it was just uh solemnizing a
a relationship very hard to find any of
these instances in which the people
didn't have lots of other good choices
of people who would gladly observed
their business and uh so again it gets
me thinking about Zora Neil Holston oh
are you just trying to say in order to
make a point
yeah uh zornale Hurston is uh somebody
who we can all do we can all benefit
from uh you know thinking about a lot
more and looking at her life as
certainly her literary output but but
there's a real sense of tragedy there
and Coleman I know that you're familiar
with Zorn Neil Hurston who you know was
uh also a Columbia student uh back in
the day and studied with Franz Boaz and
the anthropology department and suffered
real massive indignities is that
uh you know on the account of both her
gender and her race but I mean is it
that we are in a stage now and it's
always you know uh it you know we're
always declaring Victory way too soon in
all kinds of Wars right but like is it
the world that she lived in and that
level of anger and hate and contempt for
sexual minorities for racial minorities
for ethnic minorities is that mostly
behind us and is that something that we
need to incorporate into our
contemporary discussions of things
it's interesting I'm of two minds on
this on the one hand I think we have
made massive progress in people's
attitudes
towards minorities uh racial minorities
sexual minorities Etc
on the other hand I don't think that
these bigotrys will ever be gone fully
and permanently I think
um I I I think Human Nature has a
bigoted element to it that is reducible
but not eradicable
and and uh
uh at some level we're going to be
living with some amount of racism some
amount of homophobia until the end of
time and we should
while combating it we should understand
that
yeah
um uh Wally can I ask from uh you know
and again this is going back into the uh
you know kind of libertarian subculture
people like Milton Friedman talked about
this as well as a wide variety of other
people whose motivations may not have
been as clear or as pure I think as
Friedman's but
um you know there is an argument and I
guess Gary Becker also made this another
Nobel Prize funding Economist saying you
know that businesses that discriminate
in a stupid and foolish way or and you
know well actually be punished by
markets operating
um so you know that that 303 creative
you know probably uh isn't that good a
website anyway or we'll lose enough
business uh you know that uh companies
that refuse to hire women or blacks or
you know Latinos who were good workers
um you know end up paying more higher
wages for shittier workers and things
like that is it is it more than
theoretical to say that you know markets
relatively free markets actually punish
discriminatory Behavior
it's a big topic Nick and I can offer
particular examples that back up uh
Milton Friedman's suggestions uh it's
well known I think that in the South
during Jim Crow uh railroads and others
who needed a lot of skilled Weber uh
were uh constantly seeing if they could
undermine uh Jim Crow because it was
denying them access to a lot of workers
who would have done very well and the um
it gets complicated because as Coleman
said sometimes you've got a background
of uh real uh social Prejudice in uh
that has not been eradicated and markets
can sometimes transmit that in that if
bigoted customers won't visit your
restaurant or whatever
um so I don't want to make sweeping
assertions I think that
um courts by and large uh just decide
and should decide the cases and other
bases where these things come in again
is every one of those state and local
anti-discrimination and public
accommodations laws was passed through a
legislative process in which people
could wave some of these things and I
urge people again as someone who not not
just from my libertarian standpoint but
as someone who doesn't want to see
social divisiveness
um you know that's the time to go in and
say uh are you legislating just to
demonstrate your virtue or is there
riddling of some social uh problem that
is solved by extending it from
um uh old style public accommodations to
every single little one-person operation
but you would agree that public
accommodation laws which do restrict the
right of businesses to operate however
they see fit are actually beneficial in
certain cases well I I would say from a
Libertarian standpoint
um I'd I follow I think this is the
Richard Epstein analysis I'd like to uh
confine them to the cases where there is
a practical Monopoly uh ironically uh
ends to stay for the night which were
effectively uh impractical if not a
royally granted Monopoly uh centuries
ago you know with Airbnb uh it you know
not not at all but
um you know I don't mind for utilities
and I can see at least their point uh if
someone is going to freeze the doubt of
saying uh the Inn is uh freighted with a
special public interest
um but I would make it as
um I would make it ending test that
wouldn't result in very many public
accommodations laws
I want to uh go to uh a slide we were
talking about this in the context of
affirmative action and let me just see
if where did it go uh
uh uh ah oops sorry there we go I am
just not very good at this I apologize
for
where did uh
there we go U.S support for gay marriage
on on a certain level and this is pretty
stunning in 1996 Gallup started asking
this question 27 of Americans uh thought
that uh same-sex couples should uh be
recognized by the law as valid with the
same rights as traditional marriages
it's now at 71 percent
um you know I guess I'll start with you
Wally what you know what do you think
accounts for that pretty straight line
you know massive uh increase in
acceptance of of same-sex marriage
well it is the great social Revolution
the great successful social revolution
of The Lost Generation and if I had a
one sentence explanation of why it
happened uh I'd write a book uh and some
link up is I think the
uh in that particular instance uh when
people uh got to meet their neighbors uh
by and large they realized that uh this
was something that was
um not only good for the people involved
good for the moms and dads who could see
their kids get married who thought they
would never have grandchildren uh and
also good for the water Society in many
ways uh it is judged by its outcomes and
its outcomes have been overwhelmingly uh
beneficial
um some polls recently showed a drop and
uh there's a lot of discussion of
whether the public is
having second thoughts about the whole
area because of more recent
controversies we haven't talked about
having to do with uh you know
transgender uh teens on sports teams or
whatever the thing may be
um that's for another show I think but
in this case the oh I think that course
such as so often comes closest to the
libertarian Center of uh the court in
that he uh handed down the huge victory
for gay rights a couple of years ago uh
and then came right around and clearly
as part of what he sees to be the proper
settlement of this then it says this is
not going to affect conscience rights
people who want to live as dissenters
from the consensus and lead a more
um faith-based life I think that's such
an awkward phrase is uh they will retain
all the freedoms they always had
uh Coleman uh you know and equally and
actually even more simultaneously more
disturbing but also more triumphant uh a
chart is one of uh people who find uh
interracial couples moral uh you know
Gallup and other polls when I remember
this came up a lot during Barack Obama's
presidency when he was born in the very
early 60s it was you know just a few
percent or something in America of
Americans who believe that interracial
marriage was moral uh you know now it's
in the 80s or 90s
um you know how uh what do you think
what do you think drives acceptance of
once Unthinkable kind of marriage
scenarios that's a good question I mean
one
so I mean it helps to be on the more
logical side of the argument I think
right like there was the the case
against interracial marriage and and gay
marriage just never never made sense in
in a secular context at least because
you know as the as the jokes always used
to go in the 2000s no one is forcing you
to get gay married right no one is
forcing you to get interracial like but
just knowing it's happening is Rooney
right right
when Newt Gingrich you know railed
against it and it was like while racking
up wise it was ridiculous there's that
but and in the gay marriage case there's
obviously the long-term secularization
of the country in general
it's just it's very hard to get someone
to an anti-gay position if they were
never Christian or raised with faith
it's it's tough to it'd be tough to just
argue a kid into that position
um without the background of
Christianity so as Christianity declines
I think that's that's got to have
something to do with it now on the
interracial side
I think uh the Civil Rights Movement was
a major
a major transformation in the psyche of
many Americans and obviously that the
trend took really 50 years to go from
single digit approval to single-digit
disapproval right uh but you know I I
think I'd like to think that that just
represents people making the argument
people seeing interracial couples in
movies on TV seeing it as as uh there's
like a snowballing normalcy where the
more normal it becomes the more people
think it's normal and then the more
people the more normal it becomes right
so that the people doing it don't have
to be like really the uh the most the
bravest members of society can just be
like your average Joe
how old are you Coleman 27. God damn it
you know it's like yeah you're peaking
too soon man I gotta tell you that right
now take a couple years off but you know
uh again different than Wally and me who
you know roamed with we had pet
dinosaurs and stuff like that but where
where has the individualism gone and I
realize you know that's a strange thing
to bring up in these cases but in a way
it isn't you know they're but they're
about class-based you know ethnic or or
gender or rather sexual orientation but
you know they're they're about lumps of
people that are being perceived one way
or the other and you know I was raised
to believe and it's not like uniquely
there was a rhetoric of individualism in
America that seemed to be important and
you know it's kind of Gone Missing maybe
in some way or not but I'm curious like
do you you know is individualism alive
and well with your cohort or in your
psyche you know and I think of people
like Zora Neale Hurston I think people
certainly Martin Luther King uh you know
a number of other uh you know particular
black writers or writers on Race talked
a lot about individualism and that part
of the problem with racism is that it
you couldn't be an individual you were
constantly representing this BR you know
Grand abstraction that could lead to
either being exalted or being lynched um
you know where what's the status of
individualism kind of in your Cosmos
right now I mean I would say it's alive
and well but it's become something quite
different it's become a more you know
inward looking somewhat narcissistic
kind of individualism where it's
obviously
cliche to point out but you know the the
culture of gen z uh Naval gazing about
what is my unique identity right and
it's not based on something that I've
done it's based on
you know like what do I really think my
gender identity is like last month I
thought it was this but I'm evolving and
it's this and let's have a long kind of
inward looking conversation about who I
am
um which
which really makes little reference to
like what I do and what I care about but
is is in some way more of like a style
and an aesthetic and I used to like to
dress like this but now I dress like
this and what does that say about how
I'm changing like this is the kind of
and everyone must be a kind of Miracle
of self-invention on the aesthetic front
and and the rest and I I definitely saw
a lot of that kind of individualism when
when I was in school for instance a few
years ago it's a very different kind but
it does strike me as a kind of
individualism in the sense that it's
like I have to stand apart I have to
invent myself from scratch as in as an
as an identity and I have to be
different from everyone and I have to
dress different and and so it in a way
it's still very alive it's just
transmutated I guess yeah uh Wally uh as
a uh take us out uh with uh and answer
this question
um you know the Supreme Court supports
you know a positive approval ratings
have dipped uh you know as I was saying
uh 25
of people according to Gallup have a
great deal or quite a lot of confidence
in it it's down from 45 percent uh in
1973 which is what 50 years ago
um you know uh and it's it's in lockstep
with other declines but is there
anything that the Supreme Court can do
going forward to kind of restore
it's sense you know restore confidence
and in that it is working through these
things in the way that it's supposed to
as opposed to in kind of cheap political
ways
big question and part of it is how well
they explain themselves part of it is uh
when justices dissent whether they do so
in language that undercuts the
legitimacy of the majority uh or vice
versa and part of it is a process that
you certainly can see if you look up
close to the cases that the court ticks
and how they decide them which is that
although they are not swayed by public
opinion to do things they wouldn't do
affirmatively they will sometimes duck
kisses and rule narrowly for fear of
being demonized Again by some of the
same groups that are just waiting to
demonize them I find that unhealthy I
will say
um looking back over the last few years
the courts have been one of the few
institutions the federal courts in
particular that actually have done what
they needed to during a potential
constitutional crisis you know they were
the ones who turned down all the
frivolous election suits and I worry
that
um uh sniping out them for short-term
gain over various issues that uh they
decide means that the public support
will not be there when they need to make
a perhaps
unpopular decision
upholding uh the right side in an
election dispute all right we're going
to leave it there we have been talking
with Walter Olson of the Cato Institute
look him up there in Coleman Hughes of
conversations with Coleman and at
Coleman Hughes is at Coleman
hughes.com.org.org you are a non-profit
yeah okay fair enough no but uh thank
you guys so much for walking through and
talking through these cases uh fantastic
we will see you next
Thursday at 1 pm